this one is actually a mold so it has
like a texture that oh yeah my favorite
ones are the purple my yellow we're
using bacteria as basically an agent to
paint with you can manipulate the DNA of
bacteria I want to use bacteria as a
detection agent for toxins in the
environment or for the detection of
cancer in a scientific world the focus
is actually on the applications of this
material idea relationship as an artists
are more interested in the philosophical
representational or even
interpretational level do they know what
they're going
the visiting artist program really
became active in the 1970s but even
before that you really have to go back
to jury Kepesh
who came over from the Bauhaus he landed
here and he said oh I'm in a different
environment this is an environment full
of scientists full of engineers full of
people who were trying to invent new
things I really think the artists and
the scientists have a lot to say to one
another he understood how the arts could
fit in at an institution of mi t--'s
quality and by the late 60s he had
created the Center for Advanced visual
studies the artists who were here were
not satisfied to just make art they
wanted to develop new technologies so it
just came as a kind of natural thing to
create a visiting artists program to
enhance this culture
the kinds of artists we wish to bring to
our campus our artists who have a feel
and the way they create the art that
intersects with science and technology
and to learn from us as we learn from
them if you could go into Fantasyland
and describe what would be the ideal
studio for any artist in the 21st
century you would be the MIT facilities
a lot of my work is trying to figure out
interesting ways to combine materials
with computers and through the research
I found out about Vic's work
they sent we can email immediately he
respondent is I guess I want to come by
I've heard about MIT in the media for a
long time this is a highly abstracted
image because what's going on is that
system there is throwing charged
particles of gallium at the surface Vic
has this vision of itching castles into
grains of sand and he asked me like can
we do this at MIT is there a way that we
can make an image that's so small they
can actually put it onto a grain you'll
be going through all these different
kinds of equipment creating really cool
techniques for a chewing it and then
imaging it as well
science can benefit enormously from
interacting with people were actually
concerned about how to represent the
physical world in a way that is
assessing what also understandable four
three two one zero and liftoff Trevor
Paglen came to us with this project
where he wanted to put a plaque on a
satellite in a geostationary orbit
around the earth and very likely outlive
the planet how can we encode information
into materials that can last for very
very long periods of time these
intersections between deep time and
human time are very interesting to think
about he decided to put a photographic
archive of major events in the life of
the Earthlings of this planet this is
not something I can do in my studio this
is not something I can do with materials
from you know my local art supply store
this is the kind of project that is
really only possible at a research
institution like MIT
what's really important about the
Visiting Artist program here is that
it's based on collaboration with our
existing creative arts faculty Joan
Jonas our performance artists and the
program and art culture and technology
was already collaborating with the young
jazz pianist Jason Moran a MacArthur
award winner brilliant pianist we
brought Jason here to MIT to work with
Joan to workshop a new performance piece
by Joan called reanimation Don Byron is
a brilliant jazz composer we brought him
back to MIT where he worked on a new
piece for a gospel choir
and then he composed a concerto for
clarinet for Evans abhorrent which was
performed with the student Wind Ensemble
it's just a musical feast quite
literally they had quite a rapport the
two of them students need to learn how
to play things and rhythm and make them
feel good so I think I made the thing
rhythmically difficult on purpose
my name is rubella posh and I thought
that this morning would be maybe
interesting to explain to you my method
of working putting students in contact
with people who are at the top of their
game whether it's in science or
engineering or the arts and having them
learn by creating alongside them is a
very special part of MIT educational
philosophy no rules to this you just
draw the impressions that you mcdermott
of work is one of the highest level
artist Awards in the world in all cases
the people who get the award spend some
time at MIT with the students in some
classes it's more than an honor it's
also an opportunity to benefit from the
creative culture here on campus any
questions any any doubts and fears when
you're starting out you're an amateur at
this
you don't know if what you're doing is
going to go off in the right direction
within having someone who's done it all
their life and successful at it and
coming to MIT and working with you and
making you feel that you're part of the
process let's to feel that you
definitely have a chance doing good work
but don't be nervous
you know for the young conductor the Los
Angeles Philharmonic Gustavo Dudamel
came here to receive the award to bear
Lapage the Canadian theater maestro
everything he does it all with
experience we've learned that we should
not force connections we let them and
eventually two or three things seems to
go together and we go there's a pattern
there I've never really seen the quote
unquote division between the Arts and
Sciences as any kind of dichotomy to be
a complete person it makes sense to be
educated at both so having a vibrant
arts program at a school like MIT it is
important for making complete human
beings for making human beings that
connect to the world asking questions
that haven't been asked before when you
put the artist into the mix I think
those questions become larger they
become more speculative and they also
have this human dimension this one is a
mistake it's not a actual experiment but
it still looks really cool working with
Vic has really made me think about the
whole cycle of Technology and art and
how those two are interwoven and it's
just a beautiful cycle connecting nature
and the high technology that we practice
here it would be really interesting to
film on a microscope all the details
there there's a lot of intricate stuff
going on like some bacteria are swimming
in other bacteria are just climbing on
top of each other and they like to
communicate
you